una hernia inguinal es una afección
donde el contenido abdominal como el
intestino sobresale a través de punto de
debilidad en una zona de la ingle
llamado el canal inguinal
a medida que el intestino empuja a
través de este punto débil se forma un
saco de hernia con el tejido que reviste
el interior del abdomen llamado
peritoneo que lo rodea el intestino
puede quedar atrapado o encarcelado
dentro del saco de la hernia con el
tiempo
el suministro de sangre puede cortarse
esto lleva a la estrangulación donde el
tejido en el interior del shower diario
muere
una reparación laparoscópica de la
hernia inguinal totalmente extra
peritoneal requiere solo pequeñas
incisiones en el abdomen conocidas como
puertos
para llegar a la hernia el cirujano
inserta un tubo llamado trocar a través
de un puerto situado justo debajo del
ombligo
este instrumento se utiliza para separar
la pared abdominal interior del
peritoneo luego se infla un globo que
rodea el instrumento para crear un
espacio para que el cirujano trabaje
a continuación el cirujano inserta en
laparoscopia a través del puerto
umbilical
las imágenes de la cámara se transmiten
a un monitor de vídeo de la sala de
operaciones
una vez creado el espacio de trabajo se
insertan dos trócares adicionales
el cirujano pasará los instrumentos
quirúrgicos a través de ellos estos
instrumentos se utilizan para separar
los elementos adheridos a la bolsa de la
hernia y para sacar el intestino
suavemente fuera del canal inguinal y
volver a introducirlo en el abdomen para
evitar que algo vuelva a ingresar por la
apertura el cirujano coloca una pieza de
malla sobre ella y la fija en su lugar
con grapas
las incisiones se cierran con suturas
seguido de adhesivo para piel o cinta de
cierre para piel si se presentan
complicaciones con el procedimiento
laparoscópico el cirujano cambiará a un
procedimiento abierto con una incisión
más grande